[Music]
Jimmy whoa [ __ ] all United I remember
reading the first few chapters of my
hero academia back in 2014
Naruto was coming to a close and the
torch was about to be passed down to the
next great shown in series
it's funny how both Naruto and my hero
academia have the inherited will of the
next generation as a major theme I think
in reality my hero academia is inherited
a lot that the previous generation has
developed and made it its own in the
same way deku inherited his powers from
all might and is now making them his own
too I don't know whether this similarity
is by accident or whether the author
horikoshi is inspired by his own
situation and is making a focal point of
his series well hopefully some of these
awesome moments are going to inspire you
to get into the series or if you've
already watched the show it will remind
you of why you like it so much
[Music]
starting off at number 10 it's the
entrance exams final moment at the start
of the show our main character midoriya
was pretty much a loser
in a world full of special abilities he
was a quark 'less nobody and to make
matters worse he wanted to be a
superhero it's like waiting to be a pro
basketball player but not having any
arms he's recognized for his courage by
all might who luckily for him has the
gift of being able to transfer his
ability to another person it's all about
the hero's journey here a lot of shown
in shows start this way but then they
get that one moment to shine and this
was Midori us first oh yeah this is
gonna be amazing moment
[Music]
Cinco de face
fish tee up scum
at number nine we have all my versus
midoriya and back we'll go some lessons
are learnt the hard way the really hard
way hit over the head hard slammed in
the ground hard
stepped on hard the inspirational quote
goes nothing in life hits as hard as
life well I'm pretty sure all my hits
harder I think this is one of those
moments that made buckle go one of the
most popular characters in the show
here's I'm not gonna back down attitude
and no matter what the difference in
strength is I'll destroy whoever I'm
facing mentality makes you love him even
though he's a massive prick a massively
lovable prick
[Music]
moving on to number eight we have buckle
goes rescue this was a close one
a lot of us thought that we were gonna
lose bark will go here as well luckily
for us though he's a badass that spits
at the arm the villains League extends
to him this arc starts off tense with
the third villains League attack now
bolstered by the new recruits they
kidnap Barca go and tried to recruit him
he gives them a hell no and then it all
accumulates through an epic rescue
orchestrated by midoriya the type that I
would have perhaps wanted to see in
another show 15 years ago
[Music]
number seven it stains rage moment
although awful one is stronger for most
of us stains the best villain of the
show so far I think we all just love
people who don't back down when facing
challenges larger than themselves and
characters that have strong consistent
values the hero killers just like that
sure his goal was to murder a bunch of
pro heroes too but he's doing it out of
his own twisted desire to purge Society
of all the fake heroes and it's still
admirable how when faced against so many
heroes he doesn't back down he even
saves midoriya from a villain because he
thinks he's someone who deserves to be a
hero when endeavor the second strongest
hero shows up the stain run away No
he calls him a fake and starts walking
towards him that's the kind of attitude
we all need to have just without the
killing part
[Music]
next on the list at number six is when
Todoroki uses his left two things make
this moment amazing for me the first is
Totoro Keys personal growth my hero
academia has a diverse and well-made
supporting cast and Todoroki is one of
my personal favorites he's someone with
the most natural talent out of all of
the next generation students and yet he
suppressed his half of it because of his
relationship with his father this is the
moment where he gets over his inherited
past and looks towards his own self-made
future the second is the mentality of
midoriya he encourages Todoroki to use
his full power to get over his mental
issues and grow as a person and this
opposes his personal goal of the moment
to win the match but it serves the
greater goal of having a peaceful world
by helping the Allies grow as heroes
middle you
[Music]
cuckoo
number five it's all for one's
introduction I'm really glad that in
anime the villains are rarely overlooked
they play a crucial role in every series
and that's something I've covered in the
top ten and tagging is groups in anime a
hero's only as strong as the villains he
faces with the exception of one punch
man of course the brighter the light the
darker the shade all for one is the
darkness to all might slight as much as
all might is loved all for one is feared
his presence powers and dark philosophy
all accumulate into one of the best and
most chilling antagonist introductions
I've seen in Shonen anime
[Music]
salty
next on the list at number four is when
midoriya defeats muscular while there
doesn't seem to be any official power
ranking in my hero academia muscular was
probably the most powerful opponent
midoriya face up to this point in the
show midoriya was once again pushed far
beyond his limits when trying to protect
someone this characteristic of his was
the reason why all might picked him as
his successor we saw that he made the
right choice when deku managed to put
everything in his attack to defeat
muscular against all odds
it also shows why stain saved midoriya
and thought he's worthy of being a hero
midoriya has consistently placed his own
life in danger to save others from
danger and in these moments is where
he's always managed to shine the most
and entertainer
[Music]
welcome heal
[Music]
[Music]
una de Guerra
at number three we have all might versus
no move the first attack of the league
of villains was the first time we saw
some organization on the villains part
the attack gave a lot of the students a
chance to shine Midori especially but no
one got as much of the spotlight in the
attack as all might all might is a
godlike figure that no one's been able
to push at that point in the series
except for his own health no move the
artificial human made by one for all
with the explicit purpose of defeating
all might has the ability of shock
absorption meant to counter all might
strength
this epic fight gave us the first full
extent of all mites powers both his
physical strength and his mental
fortitude to overcome his own boundaries
and push himself past his illness and
limits
pseudo up
in second place it's the second fight
between midoriya and baku go unlike
others who grow up with their quirks
refining them and making them stronger
as they grow one for all's already a
full-grown quark that's given to someone
who has no idea how to use it it's like
giving a machine gun to a toddler but
then the person who received the
one-for-all grows much faster than
anyone
so from barkal gos perspective it must
be infuriating to see the weak point
he's known since childhood has now
caught up or might even overtake him
it's a lesson about not comparing
yourself to others while both of these
boys have grown up in strength
substantially Barca goes not looking at
his own growth but looking at Dec oohs
instead of finding joy in his own growth
he finds pain in the growth of his
classmate
I wonder if endeavor had this moment
with all mine
my dad
[Music]
nobody minute update some doctor
and finally at number one it's the
United States of smash all for one is
the villain above all other villains
while in the show we're seeing a
peaceful world where villains have
retreated in a recent past it wasn't
always like this at the start of the
quark era crime used to rule society at
the top of this world ruled by villains
stands
all-4-one the king of villains the
turning point of the world was probably
when all might defeat it all for one he
was the third one for all user that we
know of to attempt this and the first to
succeed what we see in the show is a
reenactment of their last fight years
ago that was probably the last time we
got to see all my to his full strength
and it was glorious
stop
[Music]
well thanks for watching and this time
we are having a giveaway so leave a like
and subscribe if you haven't already and
you might be the lucky person chosen to
inherit all Mike's quirk I'll see you
next time on Vinny tube